ladies and gentlemen thank you for
coming
um I am operating here against several
very considerable disadvantages first of
all my distinguished opponent who
proposes to play the entire ring for you
on the piano until you surrender
then my chair who is as you know a card
carrying wagnerian that is honest honest
is the day as long very possibly but I
took a look at his party card and its
number is almost as low as Michael
Portillo's
against these two very considerable
disadvantages I also have your own inner
feelings as you entered these these
premises this Hall the former Alberto
Villar Hall
um as you as you entered you were asked
which you preferred Verdian or Wagner
And if you were sure that nobody was
listening you said Verdi but if you
wanted to impress your partner you said
Wagner didn't you I could see a lady in
the fourth row yes
um
you did didn't you because you thought
that's going to make me look a better
person it's going to make me look more
intelligent more appreciative I can do
the big things where whereas Verdi has
been the object of a vicious propaganda
campaign and written off as just another
Italian Tunes tunesmith an organ grinder
to to to Wagner's Pantheon of sound
so we're operating against that
prejudice as well and he did very
himself was operating against that
prejudice even though he enjoyed success
before Wagner in 1842 with nabuko he
started earlier he was the first to get
going
um
from the middle of his life from the
1860s we'll come to that in in a little
while he was forever being berated by
his own Italians for not being more like
Wagner
Wagner was the monkey on his back so in
a sense some of the argument that I have
to present tonight is the argument that
Verdi himself was presenting against the
wagnerian tendency against the wagnerian
superiority
so these These are quite considerable uh
opponents ladies and gentlemen I don't
underestimate them and and you know if I
will be happy to get away with the two
to one majority tonight
I think we need to Define terms what do
we mean by Verity versus vague now you
can't actually say one's music is better
than the other because they are so
different in any way you can't compare
music at this level you are what are you
comparing you're comparing apples and
peaches aren't you
um I mean if one was going to be a
little unkind to Wagner you would say it
was granny Smith's against some luscious
Italian fruit but no we won't be on
let's not be unkind to Wagner it's not
that kind of event we'll be very polite
to him studiously polite
um
what are the terms then by which we can
judge these two great summer tears of
their art because there is no greater
figure in Italian opera than Giuseppe
Verdi and no greater figure in German
Opera than than the Richard now what I
would prose I hope my uh distinguished
opponent will agree is that we look at
two criteria one is how each of them
changed the course of Music certainly of
their own art form and the other is how
each of them changed the world
let me perhaps begin with a little bit
of biography just to get us up and
running I don't I don't suspect you will
you've all swallowed growth before you
came in
both are born in 1813 Wagner in May
um Verdi in October Wagner is a city boy
he's born in Leipzig Verdi is born in a
village a practically scrubland a really
non-descript place called larongole and
he is born into a family that as they
say has seen better times and there's
probably nothing worse than to be born
into a family that feels itself on the
slide they once owned a lot of property
and they they now earn very little and
they are practically living a peasant
existence dependent to do to some degree
on charity for their survival this is
not a good environment in which to grow
up but fortunately catches the eye of a
man called Antonio barezi in the nearby
town of bosetto and he baretsi sees his
talent and supports the boy and puts him
through school and then puts him through
conservatory and then verily goes and
marries but it's his daughter Margarita
and is looking forward to live happily
ever after and to settle down and write
operas and he starts doing that without
any impact at all he's 26 practically a
grandfather in Italian terms before his
first opera gets staged every major
Italian composer has had an opera on
stage at around 20 or 21 then he waits
until 26 before he gets there and it is
of course a flop
so
um
he decides to take the family to Milan
because that's clearly where Opera is
going to be where his fortune is going
to be made or broken and three fateful
things happen first of all his little
boy's 17 months old dies of a childhood
illness
they come to Milan and his daughter
Falls sick and his wife pawns her few
jewels to try and keep the family
together the daughter dies
finally
the worst blow of all his wife dies
he is in his late twenties now and he's
totally bereft and he has two choices
he can go back to the Village
or he can write nabuko
well we know what he did he wrote nabuko
and the effect
in 1842 of nabuko is enormous it
resonates still to this day because with
nabuko with vapencio he defines the
Italian aspiration of nationhood but not
in a nationalist sense the key thing to
remember about Verdi is he is never a
narrow Nationalist and the proof of it
is the story that he takes for nabuko
which is the story of the Hebrew slaves
in Babylon they've been expelled from
their land they are scorned they are in
Handel's term despise it and rejected
and they are they are the downtrodden
equally of Europe uh they are constantly
railed against in in church pulpits the
Jews are are the Jews are our misfortune
Verdi is the first European composer to
make an opera of the fate of the Jews
and to use that as a paradigm for the
fate of all oppressed people in Europe
and in the world and this is what takes
off in 1842.
only handle in the entire history of
music only Handel has presented Jews as
Heroes on the stage and that is in
oratorio on the last occasion it was
Judas Maccabees it's exactly a hundred
years before that Handel wrote Judas
maccabeus a hundred years until Verdi
comes along and says
the Jew is the oppressed in us all
what is he doing here in Valencia what
is he saying to us
he's saying Italy and Italians have the
right to self-determination they have a
right to stand up tall among the Nations
they have a right
to be like the English to be like the
French the Germans didn't yet exist uh
to be free people in their own land but
not in any narrow sense they need to
respect other cultures they need to
recognize that the Hebrews who are so
scorns also have a similar right and
that if Italy is ever to be a state
which will earn World respect it will be
a state of Tolerance it will be a state
of multiculturalism ladies and gentlemen
how modern how 21st century is that
I might Act
how Stark is that in contrast
to Richard Wagner
who at the time that Verdi is presenting
nabuko is starting to write his
notorious tract on jewishness in music
in which he proposes that minorities and
Jews in particular are excluded from
European culture the first known case of
cultural ethnic cleansing why Verdi
that's one very good reason
we look on
the developing the unfolding career of
this astonishing musician
1842 we said nabuko after that it's one
or two operas every year there are 40
altogether nobody remembers them all
except possibly the late Edward Downs
John Tom you'll remember him
um the late Edward Downes who tried
valiantly to perform all 40 in this
place
let me give you some highlights 1842
nabuko 1847 an absolute smirabilis
Macbeth which very considered his
greatest to date
in November Jerusalem three major operas
in a year and then we come to March 1951
and over the next three years
unbelievable
the Summits of Italian opera
some of the most performed operas of
this day Stephen you were saying which
is the most current who has performed
553 times
since
2008-9 season right up to the state and
and uh enrigoletto pretty close they're
pretty close writing in the 1850s he is
still speaking to the vox populi of the
2010s
impossible impossible to imagine the
effect that these operas had on their
audiences
in one of the lesser-known operas there
is a scene where the hero jumps off a
balcony and people in the audience got
so excited by this that two of them
jumped off the balcony into the
orchestra
fortunately no no musicians were harmed
in the making of This production we're
told we can't be too sure about the
reporting from Italy